i've been figuring out my gay awakenings
oh my god give it to me let's go jojo
siwa
is not holding back when it comes to
opening up about her sexuality
it's just awesome on wednesday the teen
superstar who came
out as a member of the lgbtq plus
community in january
appeared on 4d with demi lovato spilling
all the tea
on her first few sexual awakenings i
think i realized that my very first gay
awakening was jenna dwan's performance
on lip-sync battle
[Music]
but that wasn't the only awakening jojo
said she had
the 18 year old performer also admits
that it was demi
and one of her dancers that also opened
her eyes
do you remember your dancer uh her name
is jojo gomez
and you did cool for the summer together
i remember seeing that and just being a
little too interested
[Music]
jojo also revealed that even her
girlfriend kylie prue
also had the same awakening during
demi's cool for the summer era
she said she went to your concert and
it was it was that concert and she would
have probably had to have been
12 maybe 13. and
she was there with her mom and she said
after the show my mom was like that
wasn't great her mom's australian so she
was like
this great show wasn't it and kylie was
like yup
she's so great shortly after coming out
earlier this year
jojo began dating kylie which she
publicly announced on the tonight show
with jimmy fallon
it is true i do have the most amazing
wonderful perfect most beautiful
girlfriend
on their one month anniversary jojo
introduced kylie on instagram
describing her as the most loving
supportive happiest protective
and just the most beautiful perfect
person in the world
now jojo's revealing to demi that her
decision to go public with their
relationship
wasn't easy the only thing that held me
back from telling the world
right away was my girlfriend's family
and my girlfriend because i wanted to
make sure that like she was ready
and now that jojo is living her true
authentic life
she explained to et last year that when
it comes to her music
her fans can still expect the same
signature
jojo
[Music]
everyone is like you're gonna be 18 are
you gonna change the show
and i'm like no people are coming to see
me and my unicorn they're coming to see
me and my big bow they're coming to see
me staying with bobo they're coming to
see me living on a rainbow bridge that's
what they want to see
give them give the people what they want
you know everyone wants to have a good
time and a good night
and i think eventually you know i will
grow up past that and i think cobb the
unicorn will have a lovely garage in my
house one day and always be a part of my
life and i think
my front door will always have a hair
bow on it it's who i am